i found this thing that when i moved
outwards
and breathed
[Music]
every time i did that i was centered in
the character and i knew what i was
doing and i knew where i was
and i was moved
i'm going to give you the actor
director's perspective
applying my 50 years in the film
industry to your movies
you're going to experience the way that
i like to work with the screenwriter so
i reached out to my good friend scott
frank
and we will be looking at character
we'll be looking at structure we'll be
looking at tone
i really love how you just smashed into
that flashback
it feels right there's a lot of lines
that you could do with looks right the
second line to the bottom i would add
for
sake to give her a little attitude
[Music]
you act and direct at the same time it's
a balancing act
actors tend to focus on the moment but
directors have to do more than that
the director is the leader you're never
going to know
every single thing that your crew member
knows but what you do have to have is a
unifying language of vision
as a leader you have to make a decision
and then support that decision
but it's important that you know that
you're going to be filled with anxiety
what is this movie going to be how
should i redo the script is it gonna be
okay
you have to learn to trust that you will
be inspired
and what i've come to learn is that
eventually i'll be standing there and it
will come
that's something that took a long time
to learn
the truth is that everything that you
have to know is inside of you
every decision-making process is
instinctual can come from within
and as long as you have a pen and a
paper to write it down you're in good
shape
i'm jody foster and this is my master
[Music]
class
you